if you follow my channel you may have
noticed that I've been putting out a lot
more content than normal recently and
many have accused me of being an
artificial Intel intelligence I hate to
admit it but there is some truth to that
I've partnered with AI researchers to
build tools that Empower creators and
we've been Alpha Testing them in stealth
mode for the last month and I feel like
Barry Bonds in 2001 where I can just
knock it out of the park every day it
seems kind of unfair but the good news
is that these tools will be available to
everyone in the not so distant future
the first thing you should have noticed
by now is that my voice is entirely
artificial researchers took hundreds of
hours of my voice and reversed mapped it
to their encoder decoder turbo
encabulator Transformer based on open
ai's whisper technology and it almost
sounds real having a high quality clone
voice is nice but it's not the thing
that makes me productive the time
consuming part of making videos is all
the writing code and editing that's
required but what's crazy though is that
I don't do any of that by hand anymore
instead it's all handled by a multimodal
bioavailable generative retrained
transgender model which will soon be
Unleashed on the world as gpt6 a
scientific marketing brochure will
explain all the details soon but the
secret sauce is human DNA rather than
store all the weights and biases on
Silicon chips we store them directly on
living tissue did you know it only takes
one gram of dried human DNA to store 455
exabytes of data that's the capacity of
multiple data centers and enough space
to store the entire GPT data set and
Beyond but the tricky part is that we
need the DNA to be wet and alive and
that means we need to deliver it into a
living host luckily for that we were
able to partner with Pfizer to use their
safe and effective mRNA technology to
propagate the GPT model throughout the
human body once injected the MRNA
teaches our cells how to train the GPT
model as an end user to print it all you
have to do is think of a thought in your
brain
that will trigger an immune response
that then transmits the chat GPT
response back into your brain sounds
pretty awesome so when they offered me
early access my response was an emphatic
hell yes because you guys deserve the
best YouTubers that science can create
they flew me out to Korea for the
procedure and here's how things went
Hello friends Dr Haywood jablomi here we
here at the open AI bio Labs team are
are big fans of fireship and reached out
to Jeff to see if he'd be willing to try
our new GPT 6 embedded model but with
any new AI technology there are some
safety concerns after receiving the
first injection sadly the test subject
died an extremely painful and agonizing
death we [__] up pretty bad but that
didn't leave us discouraged our team was
able to extract his
encephalon and put in a Ziploc bag we
then put some jumper cables on it and
hooked it up to a Raspberry Pi allowing
us to prompt DPT sex entirely from a
self-contained biological system and
well the results speak for themselves
we're calling this groundbreaking new
model Jeff my name is Jeff juxtaposed
encephalon for filmmaking and will be
available soon in a Microsoft product
near you while technically inside of you
and that means you'll be seeing a lot
more content from your favorite creators
so make sure to smash smash that
subscribe button in fact this is your
last warning if you watch my videos and
are not subscribed just hit the button
and that'll be the end of it but if you
don't I will look for you I will we'll
find you and I will for the love of God
subscribe to goddamn Fire Ship while you
still have time thanks for watching and
I will see you in the next one